hello there Luca and Richard I see now
you're both in Europe and of course
Europe is going through an economic
crisis so they can't afford much
fighting over there so you're both going
dark but on the lights not long enough
to reach me listen you were recently in
Moscow where I saw both of your
presentation I have to say that both of
you have a very relaxed engaging
delivery style quite different from when
we only see the sort of close-up of your
head you know on the YouTube videos so I
thought I thought it was it was very
well done congratulations thank you I
would like to hear a little bit about
your experience in Moscow what you're
expecting in Budapest and this
phenomenon of of I collet
language-related travel or polyglot
tourism okay Richard wanna go first okay
well I have to say that the experience
in Moscow was exhilarating was really
great I didn't expect all that to tell
you truth because it was the real first
language conference that I attended and
I have to say that it was very
interesting in very well organized and
very interesting and everybody was
sharing their ideas and they let us
speak about whatever we wanted to talk
about and it was great in general yeah
it was I mean it was um it was really
good I mean we I think we both went to
you to sort of an academic type
conference in Italy and this is a real
sort of conference there was more sort
of the style that we look in on YouTube
giving down
that's all advice factual help in both
Rinnai presentation as you didn't sleep
and then we did a master fossa fall day
and during the master buss we gave sort
of tips advice into people to really
chew on to think about in terms of
language learning and and that was in
frontof of people who you wanted to come
to just specific or listen to what you
have to say I think that Richard has a
point there because what I want to add
is that a lot of conferences especially
the one we had in partner there were a
lot of interesting speakers obviously
but they were talking about academic
stuff that a lot of people actually
don't understand now there's a value in
academia etc etc but I do believe that a
lot of people are interested in
practical ways to learn languages so
that's what happened in in Russia and
that's not what happened in in part my
it was still a very interesting
conference but when we spoke we spoke
about practical things and people were
even a little bit surprised
eating teachers were in the audience
they were like taken aback by the fact
that we're talking so practically about
language it was I believe that when you
have to speak about languages if you
have an audience and they are interested
in language learning and that's a
practical thing I believe so instead of
talking about you know fanatics and
stuff it just got to the point and
that's what happened Russia and that is
what is happening in what is going to
happen in Budapest hopefully American
Council for teachers of foreign
languages ACF TL or something conference
in San Diego and I attended a thing
called the sprocket booth in I believe
was distilled or Ferg somewhere and yeah
there's a lot more academic presentation
and there seems to be sort of the flavor
of the of the month you know that
everyone will talk about you know the
English is now an international language
you needn't learn it from a native
speaker anymore which to me always
strikes me as nonsense yeah well
as overstated let's put it this way the
majority of English teachers are not
native speakers however most people
learning a language are more inspired to
hear and to model themselves on a native
speaker even though they may get advice
from you know when when we thought about
the conference in Budapest the very
first thing that occurred to us is that
we want to make it practical now and I
want to highlight this point one more
time it's not that I want to bash
academia I think there's a value I am
reading a lot of interesting books about
phonetics for might work for example and
I do believe that they're very
interesting but I also do believe that
you know this is kind of an alternative
it's a very first time that polyglots
talk about language learning in
different fields like raising a
multilingual kid or how to become an
interpreter how to use languages for
work etc so I believe there's some value
in and that's the very first reason why
we decided to do this conference know so
I mean as I said it's sort of people who
have been successful many times through
some of the speakers at the event and
now Budapest is is all about bringing
together all of the different stories
that you can go into the languages so
offering advice on learning giving
practical health advice to people who
want to learn language whether it's at
first whether it's a 21st and by the
10th at the same time what we want to do
is take some of these elements of
academia that are interested looking for
and that people want to know about so
that maybe they can pursue by their own
studies later on taking that and taking
you mentioned team conferences you went
in the academia and the work conference
to take also professions like Luda
mentioned
interpreting as one but there are other
professions as well that people can get
into using languages and to introduce
them in a more neutral setting
so it's not going to be this headhunting
where after you it's not as another
interview this this is so that could
mean it's all very theoretical it's
going to be an overview of everything so
that you can sort of capture all of the
relevant and interesting topics
surrounding languages under one umbrella
and make it accessible for anybody out
there to be able to to get links and
find out more information to put me in
touch with the right people that's the
whole idea in the whole concept of
conferences right through the to the
British to speak here of three or four
or five languages who's looking for
professional opportunities and advice on
how to how to make those languages you
know not pay for them but in other words
I have a question I was just going to
say that and the the name polyglot
conference is really something that
attracts these polyglots to come
together to do what we very rarely get
to do and that's to speak lots and lots
of languages in person and interact with
each other in one place and that's
something that hasn't really been done
before in this way so this is why it has
the title all of our conferences why
it's unique and and why it has a sort of
a draw for people with multiple
languages to come and attend but it has
ramifications in sort of the whole
language community really something that
I think we will probably agree that
anyone can do we agree on that 100
percent okay so we don't think that
polyglots are it wasn't that they fell
out of the crib and landed on the you
know corner of their head and that just
like anybody you know and it's it's like
if you do one you can do two and if you
can do - you can do three and so
everyone the question I have is
obviously you know and this can rock on
perfect well the very first thing that I
that I do is they tell every single
student that I haven't and they tell
everybody is you have to learn how to
learn it is a lot of people think you
know is there a one best method etc etc
and the thing is that as I said in nine
lighted nd and the conference in Moscow
there is no one best method you have to
figure out what suits you best a lot of
people actually have no idea how to
learn a language from scratch and what I
try to do when I try to do in Moscow for
example especially in the master class
more than the speech in the the first
day is to tell them look it's a trial
and error process it's not a science
it's not rocket science you know I have
to figure out what to do it's very
practical so I the very first thing that
I do is to work on their psychology
psychological factor they a lot of
people think that they can't learn a
second language for me it's evident that
you can do it but for most for a lot of
people it's not evident at all like they
try to say oh it's impossible you know I
will never how do you do that like if I
were an extraterrestrial something
say I am NOT one other misunderstanding
is that when people see us speak 20
languages 15 12 they think we're like
some sort of genius born with a rare
breed and that's absolutely not true if
you see people in Congo and Locsin Berg
they speak four or five languages
because there's a lifestyle they do it
because they use it so what I do for
example when people ask me how do you
keep so many languages in your mind how
do you keep them active is this simply
because it shows a job and when it comes
to speaking a lot of languages you have
to make choices in life like every day
what I did for example is I decided to
work with languages I hold a degree in
electronic engineering and then I told
myself of course I could use languages
at work but if I if I use them if I work
with languages I could you know use
languages every single day so a
lifestyle and mentality is very
important that's even more important
than the method itself you know people
focus and talk so much about that's the
best method no my method is better yet I
think it's the car that you're missing
the point if we see the best way to
understand this is that I am with steve
richard buccola it's the three of us we
all have different approaches but we
have a lot of things in common so when a
person is trying to get the best out of
everybody I think they should look at
the come of the things that are coming
and the you know and us and I think we
have a lot of things in common
even if obviously we disagree on some
aspects of language learning whatever
but that's normal that's that's a big
first thing that I tell everybody you
know you first have to understand how to
learn a language and have a positive
mentality because learning language is
not as difficult as a lot of people
think I see it clearly now that I speak
ten languages and I think you have the
same vision where I believe I assume I
am I mean really only after what you
said and you know for me all about true
motivation is really important and I
like to see the person as a whole so
whether it's a young child or an adult
language learner you have to take the
whole person and not just the language
because people people don't sort of live
their lives in vacuums so language
learning can't act in a vacuum either
you can't just do it and say okay you're
learning a language and that's it you
need to need to see what their lives are
like and it's all very individual so you
know how someone thinks have someone
learns it's all really key to hone in on
what works best for their environment
their personality their particular
situation then moon driven and give them
tools to be able to motivate themselves
to carry on learning the program to
their needs so there has to be and I
think I think we I feel that it's it's
nice that there are people who speak
five six seven languages and go to
polyglot conferences but if I look here
in North America you know very few
people speak more than one language yeah
yeah didn't remote link as an as one way
of looking everybody we actively promote
link as one learning but but really link
like there are some of the common
elements are what like first of all
obviously motivation if you're not
motivated you're not going to learn yeah
you know you be positive don't allow
yourself to be frustrated it takes a lot
of time it takes some other time now I
always say do things and I noticed that
liquor said the same thing do things
that you enjoy drink don't don't push
yourself at some method of learnings you
don't enjoy so those are some things
that are in assignment where we disagree
is some people like to speak right away
some people like to spend a fair amount
of time I mean put before but start
speak think this is gonna
people's personality to some extent but
if you were to say look I say if you
okay here are three things that are in
common that all successful language
learners have in common what would those
be well I first passion and motivation I
would say second I would say that we all
have you know when we start learning the
language
maybe I'm just talking about myself but
a set clear goals immediately a lot of
people have unclear goals so you just
want to learn a language for the sake of
it
but if you make it clear that you're
learning a language for some reason
maybe because you want to want to find a
wife because you want to live in the
country etc I believe that in my case
for example when it comes to when I
started learning Polish it was some some
months ago I was a visitor Richard in
Poland and was immediately clear to me
that I wanted to learn polish for a
reason that is to use to use polish to
maybe live in Poland and the same thing
goes for Japanese a lot of people ask me
for example I want to or tell me sent me
messages and say I want to learn
Japanese and I ask them why because
there's no reason if you don't have a
clear objective and I think you're gonna
lose track and you're gonna you know
you're not gonna follow the path to the
end this is one other thing for example
when you start learning languages you
want to I want to use them there are a
lot of people who dabble in languages
like speaking a little bit have a
smattering of the language but as far as
I'm concerned every single language that
I learn once I said I say I tell myself
date X that's the beginning of the
adventure and I want to bring it to a
level where I can use it so the fact of
having clear objectives for me is
extremely important
so apart from motivate and that
motivates me that's a that's a virtuous
circle every time I learn something
thirty minutes I imagine myself speaking
the language going to the country and so
on that that is except that fuels my
language study and well motivation
obviously and then you know this having
clear goals me determined learn every
maybe you don't learn everyday you
but I do try to learn every single day
you know I you know I try to get it I
miss a day or two but the goal is trying
to be honored every day for children
that's you know when you see for example
I was back in the from from Russia week
ago and I saw that my my pie hadn't
touched polish I maybe I spoke with in
Polish with Richard in the car but it
was a very brief conversation and I saw
that it's like feeding your brain it's
literally feeding your brain so you just
try to do it a lot of people think I
don't I don't have the time it's not
that we don't have the time it's that we
don't make the time because as I as I
said with your mp3 if you have developed
good strategies and you put something in
your mp3 you go to the supermarket
washing the dishes except for you can
try you can feed your brain constantly
so you have no excuse so nicely with
liking with the same motivation and
reason why can pursue regular study and
the other thing I'd say that's key is
finding content that stimulates you
that's accessible to you and is easy for
you to use there are the three key
things I think we are confident we know
that they're good at learning languages
that's part of the motivation because
you know it's you know you know it's
like if you've never climbed a mountain
you might be reluctant apply them up
once you've done it once you say that
was fun
I can climb an Iron Mountain and another
mountain but someone who's never done it
doesn't have that confidence so so
that's something that we have to
recognize also I agree with with look
and I think rich is the same way if I'm
gonna start learning a language I want
to get to the point where I can have
intelligent adult conversations with
people I mean that's the goal I don't
want to just order a beer in the
language the other thing I think that's
important to remember is
you put in the time if you do it every
day they are almost every day that that
all the time you're putting in you are
improving so even if you're not aware of
the fact that you're improving you're
feeding your brain and you are improving
and I think tenable sometimes get
frustrated because we then have the
sense that and they have to believe that
if they put in the time they're gonna
get back absolutely one thing I just
want to follow up on what you said
BuzzFeed which is interesting you you
said that you wanted to get to this
level where you speak it really like
fluently and Luca has the same feeling
this is where I might diverge slightly
from you guys in the eye like a lot of
other people will see it a reason to be
at a certain level in different
languages so let's say for example one
of my friends wants to go to Spain I've
got a very good friend that she's my
best friend and she wanted to go to
Spain on holiday she picked up a book
and she started going critic enough to
be able to go to Spain order her meals
get around the ocean easily get to kind
of an a.1 maybe tool or 32 level and
then that was it it was plenty and she
she achieved her goal so she had a
motivation holiday she had a her horses
that she liked she found them she learnt
it to the level she needed it for the
holiday and she did it successfully and
she had a satisfaction Natarajan come
back and kick very productivity about
there where I think the language
community sometimes especially where
we're talking about people like those
who have serial language learners or
sort of extreme language learners
however you want to phrase it we tend to
sort of look upwards this different
different plane of learning maybe I
don't know but I think there's a lot of
a lot to be said for achieving a a nice
basic loving or an intermediate level if
that's what you need
there's no need to everyone to chase
this it sort of very difficult verifying
fluency or all sort of reading some sort
of obscure book or or think that's just
dollar way go for it but I think if you
don't need it for anything more
hey you're just selling hands on street
like kid ownership not yet all you need
is the words to go to here they do see
the place tell them what you're selling
and your essential languages for what
you need it for me and this office for
the same level Luke will testify I
Russian or is a little well I can
understand it pretty well my spoken
Russian plan anything you wish you can
you be going a little bit higher than
okay that's about it but it's officially
magician what I want you immune ik eight
to get around English sure I did it fine
my whole time Claire they returned with
terrible grandma but it doesn't matter
cuz that's all anymore okay I don't want
to disagree but I think I think he said
that you understand right from well my
impression might mean you speak miss as
you speak as well but I think the goal
is mentioned I had the situation when I
started lies Portuguese I went to
Portugal and I had gone actually this is
the fish habitat link I've gone through
a living language and teach yourself or
whatever I couldn't understand what they
were saying I can say what I wanted to
say and then make him back at me and I
didn't know what they were saying and so
I think comprehension like and now I'm
going to Romania six weeks ago I can
spend three days there I'm gonna go out
Romanian like a mad bandit I have no
illusions and I you know I have no
illusions but I'm gonna rent a car drive
around the country for couple days I
want at least understand something and I
doubt that I will then continue and take
it to the other level the level that I'm
talking about is not meaning obscure
books it's not seeking flawlessly it's
understanding the radio understanding
that you know the newspapers and be
imitation with mistakes I mean I speak
Russian with mistakes as well and I have
no illusions about being flawless in ten
languages but I it's the comprehension
part that's important to me
well I think that we're you're you are
interacting with for example but when I
was interacting with Russians or when I
interact with foreigners I think that
the very first thing you're calm
in a conversation when you can
understand the other person a lot of
people focus on focus on for example
fluency they say oh they constantly talk
about speaking the language but it's so
much happens that sometimes we can speak
the language but we if we don't
understand ocation is always but
bi-directional you always interact with
another person and that's the reason why
I believe that understanding is
extremely important first and I think
this is also another point a lot of
people ask me for example that's maybe
that's a trivial question why can I read
text and I don't understand the radio
can I tell them well you know there's a
few reasons for that and they are a lot
of people don't know how to build this
comprehension thing and I tell them you
know what you have to do is you have to
listen but I also believe that now in
the Internet era we have the possibility
of reading what we are listening to and
that makes a huge difference because I
always tell them look when we talk about
when you hear the language the reason
why you don't understand it is simply
because a language is of what we have it
is like a waveform and if you don't have
boundaries among words there are no
boundaries in real speech and connected
speech but we see that the boundaries
because we have this mental lexicon we
see words because we know written words
but the problem is that when you start
my first my advice I think it's sound
applies is to read and listen at the
same time you always make sure that you
understand what you're dealing with and
the reason why a lot of people give up
for example is that they don't know how
to choose interest in content and
intelligible content that is they don't
understand what you're doing if you
listen to the radio and you don't
understand it you're gonna listen maybe
for five minutes and then you're gonna
quit you're gonna say I don't understand
that it's not for me I will never
understand it and understanding like
speaking is an ability that you build up
with time but you have to know how to do
it and since we have no more excuses
because we can read and
listen for example echo echo Moskvy is
just one site it's an incredible site
you can see whatever you want there and
even in you know for example there's a
ard in a German you can watch a lot of
movies documentaries all subtitles you
can do whatever you want so there's you
just have to know where to look for it
if you know let's suppose you want to
learn German or not suppose you want to
learn a Russian obviously if you try to
understand everything in Hanko must mean
you're just a beginner you're gonna fail
because it's there pretty complicated
test once you get a smattering of the
language you can start you know
listening to it and look at forwards etc
etc and I do believe that this ability
that we have to use as adults
differently from kids at the beginning
we can actually use everything mouth
ears eyes except for etc so why don't we
take advantage of that you know that's
that's one of the most important things
ever people say oh you're doing
multitasking yeah I'm doing multitask
I'm listening and reading on the same
time especially because another thing
which I consider interesting I don't
know about you about you guys but I
constantly see subtitles in my with my
third eye and the reason why and I said
that in a YouTube video and the reason
why this you know I see subtitles is
that because I read and listen
constantly I always watch movies for
example subtitles documentaries etc etc
and this creates a bond between the
written words and sounds maybe I work my
brain works differently but I believe
that our brain work more or less in the
same way so people say oh he's a genius
because this work obviously there are
differences you know there are people
who are more gifted for some things but
we all learn the same way I always say
my the point is if you speak your native
tongue you can speak any other language
in the world if you want to that's my
point
what can I say what can I teach follow
the pian I'm lost and lost for words
I was in Mexico with the Mexican
polyglots very enthusiastic Bunch
wherever i graveled there is this
tremendous enthusiasm how are you gonna
horrible eyes this enthusiasm what are
your plans with these different
conferences or other activities how are
you gonna mobilize the enthusiasm first
of all amongst the polyglot community
wherever they're located Japan China and
Mexico you name it and be how do you
allow this to trickle down to your
average person in London or in Rome who
only speaks his or her native language
Wow first of all thank you for giving me
such a a raise in inability to be such a
thing it's the community it's the
community that needs to do this it's
individuals that into this so I don't
see myself as as this sort of live
Authority that would do this all myself
there's no way one individual and do
this whole entire was no way my
contribution to the process is together
with Luca and with other people who were
prominent in the community and who are
really active and enthusiastic to share
that and shame doesn't share that
motivation which in settings that other
people can access and he wants me to try
and get through one of the conferences
that we will now have annually and they
can come in interacting can get
motivated that way same way is this sort
of as grant importances work yes yes
brands a community so from that what I'd
like we'll see are more groups of people
getting together locally as well feeding
into think things like the Le are the
language change international and
getting recognition with them getting
more more of what they do out there to
the wider audience and that's how you
affect the local level of how people
learn languages are support
like the language loan process we saw
one really good example of this for
example in in Poznan where there's a
language grid for Spanish they meet
every week and the Polish people want to
speak Spanish want to learn Spanish and
it's and it's organized by a school in a
very center of falls man the Buenos
Aires called drink or Spanish and I'm
gonna go and talking Budapest actually
in just under two weeks at the Budapest
melting pot which has a group of people
in Budapest you get together two scripts
practice area grocery and I'll go and
active talk talk to people in an
informal way and they can kind of listen
to ask you questions interact I think
that's the way you do it you need to get
people engaged on the local level but
also have other events that they can
either go to or look to go to and get
people mostly to renew themselves
learning one other language being
confronted by a polyglot
well a lot of people tend to compare
themselves with others and that's I
think a very it's a blunder it's a
mistake because we I think they have to
compare it to themselves if you compare
yourself to Tiger Woods do you want to
play golf then well you better not start
playing golf you got to do something
else I believe that everybody is
different and if we if that person
compares with me they're comparing
apples with oranges for the simple fact
that I have I find myself in different
conditions I have a different life etc
etc so even when people compare
polyglots they're comparing apples with
oranges I believe that the very first
thing you have to do is yourself look
it's it's about personal growth
when you're learning language you do it
for yourself you don't do it for the
outer so you have to look at those
people who made it learn a lot of
languages and tell themselves they're
not dude they don't have to be role
models they just have to be people can
inspire you take the inspiration and
then you just start working on yourself
that's I think this thing of comparing
it creates envy creates a lot of
problems and a negative energy that
actually hampers people from learning
languages people are constantly worried
about being judged on YouTube for
example there's a lot of people I know
personally who are exceptional there
they're very good with languages and
they never wanted to start a YouTube
channel because they fear that they're
going to be slaughtered by other people
so I dent a 90% on a on a positive on a
positive note I have to say that the
community is very friendly for 90% of
there are some weird individuals out
there but before for the most part I
think the real you know support each
other and that's the very and I think
that when we thought about this
conference we are not we the polyglots
if you want to call this we're not there
to educate the audience we are there to
interact and share that's very different
I have a few friends coming who are
linguists or like people who speak a lot
of languages and they want to interact
they are not there to be you know
educated by the experts and that's a
very important point I can speak to
experience of what I've heard back
central feedback of course like Luca
says we're going to be people who will
have negative feelings maybe from their
own personal situation that they don't
feel adequate I really try to discourage
people from feeling that way I think
that it's it's not held cool and
everybody's got their own things that
they're good at and languages is always
a it can always be an add-on
so what lucre you Steve and and I have
done is is learn a number of languages
which let's face
for most job requirements is completely
unnecessary completely unnecessary
in practical terms you do not need to
speak but for work or most times as well
nine times out of ten to your life you
don't need to speak more than say five
six seven languages maximum I mean even
if you're living in the center of groups
and Burgin you've booked your five
languages and maybe you want to
translate Dutch so you picked up an
extra one you don't need any more than
an that ever so once you've got over
this sort of six languages I think
you're getting into the realms of okay
this is already up there in the
stratosphere for most people it is I'm
stronger with one one you might get what
what I what one of my point is is that
comparing to us is completely pointless
because it's there's no actual real use
for it in terms of what you can do extra
then you can do with an extra few
languages that's the first point I'd
like to make them someone comparing
themselves to me also equal to you is
for me totally incomprehensible it's an
extreme it's like it's games for us and
we don't get anything particularly from
doing that per se it might be a nice
benefit for a company if you work for
them to have the extra language but it's
never if we represent the next thing I'd
like to say is that if people feel and
be motivated then it's normally because
of that reason that they feel this
negativity because of the the level at
which we're learning languages the
amount of languages and that's normally
where the negativity comes in in my
experience but on the whole many people
I meet say after speaking to you I
really want to learn a language now and
I've had that said to me countless times
Eve and not just by a Facebook not just
by YouTube in person and people would
actually picked up books and started
learning and I've seen people become
fluent through that period of time one
of my very good friends in in Skopje
he always said Owen terrible language
interpret languages and he threw me has
found materials that he can use that
work for him in his busy schedule he
works and in a different place he has to
travel a lot and I've introduced in two
ways in which he can learn languages and
access materials and now because of that
he's been doing it regularly for over a
year and he's really making progress in
his in his studies so no I I don't think
it it has to be a negative thing I think
it it's it should be a positive thing
but I think the mindset of the
individual needs to be there and I think
that the determination and motivation is
probably what's lacking not as more than
this sort of who we are and what we do I
think that's good well I think that's a
good note to end on and I'll just try
min-width with my thoughts and I go back
to what Lucas said at the very beginning
that the presentation that both of you
made in Moscow was based on very
practical considerations not theoretical
not academic considerations and I think
I think that the majority of people who
hear about us or watch us on YouTube or
talk to us in fact are encouraged
because we tell people it's a lot of
work it's you know there's a lot of time
involved you have to commit but the
process itself is not difficult doesn't
require the mind of a nuclear physicist
to do so I mean anyone can do it who is
willing to do what we've done and if we
speak a lot of languages it's because we
put a lot of work into it like I don't
know many people who have put as much
work in the language learning as I do so
I think yeah I think probably most
people are encouraged and I think most
people as we've said today can do it if
they're willing to you know put the time
in and again as little said I think you
mentioned if you can and you mentioned
just recently Richard if you can find
the right kind of materials that are
interesting that are comprehensible then
and that part partly is the problem
people don't know to where to go and
find these so yeah let's just say then
that we'll continue doing what we're
doing again if I can get involved and
help but I'm sorry that I'm not involved
then in Budapest but perhaps the next
one in a in North America I can be more
involved and and and one other thing you
say we don't get anything out of what we
do it's tremendously personally rewarded
it has also helped me in my business
career in the wood business my Japanese
my pension suffered so it can also be
professionally rewarding but it is
always personally and culturally in
sorting I always say like saying that
lineage can change your life
that changed mine then that changed to
Richard's life they can change my not
only for work right ever everything ok
well we you know we could probably talk
on this subject for another couple of
hours but I think I'll cut it off here
thank you very much so I'm gonna stop
the recording and we can perhaps
summarize a little after after the fact
thank you